PaPaul Saint-Pierre Plamondon,
bobonsoir.
JeJe l'ai dit avant la pause, ls
EÉtats-Unis se débattent
hahallucinant sur les armes, les
jejeunes de dans une école, la
sésérie des enfants prix.
VoVotre parti d'autres ont des
prproblèmes, mais on peut se die
enen commençant que ça relativie
nonos problèmes sur la scène
popolitique?
- - Complètement, ce n'est pas s
prproblèmes, ce sont des débats
popolitiques qu'on connaît qui
sosont normaux et j'écoutais
jujustement les témoignages des
paparents au Texas et je me dis
ququ'au fond, il faut continuerà
gagarder espoir et à veiller sur
nonos enfants et revenir à
l'l'essentiel parce que si on vt
quque les gens continuent à
s's'intéresser à la politique eà
l'l'actualité, il va falloir ne
papas amplifier les problèmes qi
enen ont sont comme les désaccos
enentre Lucien Bouchard et moi r
cocommande granulée dépendance
QuQuébec, mais c'est important e
raramener cela à l'essentiel à
sasavoir que des tragédies comme
cecela on n'en veut pas au Québc
etet qu'on n'en souhaite pas
i il faut garder espoir là-deds
mimilité pour protéger ses
enenfants.
- - notre société est tellement
plplus saine, notre cadre
popolitique et social est plus
sasain que ce qui se passe au sd
- - je m'inquiète devant les ars
àà feu à Montréal au cours des
dedernières années et notre
inincapacité à avoir une réponse
adadéquate quand une garderie
rereçoit des balles par sa
fefenêtre, je pense que la prise
dede conscience doit avoir lieu
icici également
esest-ce une décision qui devrat
prprendre plus de passe.
- - Très bien, vous avez parlé e
MoMonsieur Bouchard, qui dans un
enentretien,
etet je le souligne :
dadans l'ensemble, oui elle aide
leles durs envers les Parti
ququébécois, bien sûr, vous l'az
enentendu, mais là aussi dit que
c'c'était courageux et qu'il avt
dudu respect pour les militants,
mamais que selon lui c'était
irirréaliste que de proposer un
réréférendum en 2022.
SuSur ce point et en particulie,
vovous répondez quoi?
- - Je respecte l'opinion de
MoMonsieur Bouchard, mais de mon
popoint de vue je ne vois pas
cocomment notre projet et nos
ididées vont avancer si on n'y
rerenonce, si on les cache dans
l'l'espace public.
SoSous ma gouverne, on assume
tototalement qu'on souhaite quee
QuQuébec devienne un pays et on
didit aux Québécois qui le
méméritent deux jours être payét
quque le plus tôt sera le mieux
ététend donné qu'L'actualité et
leles relations avec le fédéralt
lele déclin du français, tous ls
lulumineuses sont rouges il y a
unune solution pour s'offrir une
pépérennité culturelle :
çaça s'appelle indépendance
QuQuébec.
CoComme chef j'ai décidé de
l'l'assumer complètement et d'en
êêtre fier et de ne pas les
cacacher et d'en faire la
prpromotion avec le plus de
vivigueur et de fierté qu'il est
popossible de faire.
- - Mais que faites-vous dans le
cocontexte politique ou les
QuQuébécois n'en veulentnt pas e
vovotre solution?
- - Les sondages sont assez
coconstants entre 30 et 40 pour
cecent et si on se contente de
gogouverner strictement par
sosondages et que le rôle du
popoliticien et de consulter les
sosondages du jour, à quoi servt
leles politiciens?
DeDe mon point de vue le
leleadership c'est de dénoncer
cecertaines choses nécessaires
l'l'indépendance est nécessairet
ururgente à la lumière de
plplusieurs pouvoirs qui nous
écéchappent et à la lumière de
nonotre doit exister
ququand le premier ministre du
QuQuébec en vient à dire que c't
unune question de survie pour la
nanation québécoise et que dans
leles 48 heures il obtient un
rerefus,
cece n'est pas normal que ce
gogouvernement n'est même pas
cacapable de faire comme Robert-
BoBourassa est évoquée la
popossibilité de l'indépendance
nonous allons beaucoup plus loin
etet nous nous disons qu'on alls
lele faire et que c'est un projt
ririche.
OnOn peut le dire aux Québécois
enen toute sincérité.
- - oui quand Monsieur Legault a
didit que si on ne récupérait ps
nonos droits en immigration
l'l'avenir était menacé pour les
pepeuples francophones, c'est là
quque vous avez dit qu'il fallat
alaller au bout de sa logique.
C'C'est de là que c'est parti?
- - Oui et il n'a pas été capabe
d'd'évoquer le mot indépendance
unune seule fois ça va plus loi:
CaCaroline St-Hilaire et Bernard
DrDrainville se porte candidat à
lala CAQ les deux sont
cocomplètement incapables de die
lala vérité et d'être honnête ac
leles auras.
- - On n'est pas dans leur tail,
mamais ils sont incapables de de
ququ'ils sont souverainistes?
IlIls ne veulent pas le dire.
- - À mon avis, ça manque de
trtransparence avec l'électorat.
- - Prenons l'exemple de Saint-
HiHilaire et Drainville,
çaça vous arrive coup sur coup,a
vovous dit quoi sur le contexte
popolitique?
- - Via un gouvernement qui est
lalargement en avance dans les
sosondages ce qui lui permet
d'd'offrir des comtés sûrs et ds
miministères et le pouvoir.
LeLes gens de réagir différemmet
mamais ça n'empêche pas une
foformation comme les Parti
ququébécois d'attirer des gens e
ququalité qui veulent défendre a
cacause et la conviction et ça
sesera aux électeurs de choisir
paparce que pour nous,
ilil y a quand même quelque choe
dede positif dans ce qui se pas.
IlIl y a une ligne de démarcatin
trtrès claire d'un côté ceux qui
sosont résignés et ceux qui ne
veveulent pas dire la vérité
AlAllemagne quant à leurs
coconvictions,
etet de l'autre côté ceux qui st
opoptimistes et qui veulent voir
lele Québec devenir un pays et
ququ'il assume avec fierté et
hohonnêteté.
CÇa sera donc très claire pour
leles élections, de récompensese
didifférentes manières.
- - Et vous pensez qu'il faut là
mamais qui est avoir quelques
dédéputés en octobre?
- - Plus on assume et puis on et
hohonnête, j'ose croire qu'ellea
fafait et les convictions ont ue
vavaleur.
EnEn période de pandémie c'est r
quque c'était un contexte dans e
cacadre duquel les conversations
sosont notre avenir avaient mois
d'd'espace, mais une campagne
élélectorale, dans les faits, au
PaParti québécois on a rarementu
dedes gens autant reprendre leus
cacartes, les gens constatent qe
lele gouvernement actuel ne va
mmême pas au niveau nationaliste
dede Johnson ou Bourassa.
IlIls se disent que ceux qui
didisent la vérité et sont fiers
dede l'indépendance, vont le
sosoutenir.
IlIls sont hors de portée
fifièrement avec droiture ce qun
crcroit profondément.
- - Monsieur Bouchard faisait la
didifférence entre l'idée et ler
avavis doit rester éveillé et
vivivant de la souveraineté se
pepersonne connaît l'avenir, mas
auaussi la partie Québécois et
bebeaucoup de gens dans cette
sesemaine mais on oublie que leQ
a a été dur envers Monsieur
LéLévesque.
- - Avoir tous ces chefs.
- - on peut dire que les Parti
ququébécois n'est plus le véhice
ququ'il faut sans renoncer
cocomplètement à la souverainet?
- - Il y a un seul véhicule qui
prprône l'indépendance comme un
obobjectif politique qu'on doit
réréaliser un seul réel véhicule
popour dire qu'on doit aller pls
loloin avec les Français et que
l'l'indépendance est un objet
ururgent on est renouvelé et on
esest bien financé et on est
d'd'attaque parce qu'il y a une
nonouvelle génération qui lève a
mamain.
PoPourquoi ne pas encourager les
paparties qui pondent cette idée
sisi on est d'accord avec l'idée
dede on va se présenter comme on
esest.
- - Je pense que l'accumulation
dedes mauvaises nouvelles séancs
sosorte que ça met en lumière un
cecertain courage sur ce qui
rereste.
IlIl y a quelque chose peut-être
dede positif?
- - Ça attire d'autres gens qui
pepensent en patriotes.
- - Très bien.
- - Qui ne sont pas dans une
lologique de bénéfice mais qui
seservent le cause avec honneurt
onon aura une belle équipe une
frfraîcheur.
- - André Bouthillier,
a a envoyé un communiqué en dist
quque le programme n'était pas
ararrêté
paparce qu'elles ont dit que vos
n'n'étiez pas invité à parler ls
dede la cérémonie qui lance le
cocoup d'envoi des festivités et
dedes commémorations de Monsieur
LéLévesque.
MaMais on nous dit que finalemet
vovous étiez invité.
- - Je suis invité et je prendna
paparole et Monsieur Legault va
prprendre la parole et Monsieur
BoBouchard aussi.
IlIl n'y a pas d'orateur qui va
rereprésenter les Parti québéco.
- - Même pas 17 heures 4